did you ever work with chevy chase no i
never missed ever never met him no no
and it's weird because i've i worked
with marty short and i steve martin and
that the the the class
crossed my heart and with martin short
you made out with martin short oh my god
you'd have sex with well fake sex kind
of kind of yeah
what was that like by the way
it was fantastic the best thing about
that movie was that it it was shot
almost like a play
because it was mostly just the two of us
and there was some book end scenes but
it was mostly just the two of us in this
apartment and so we just do it in order
which is so rare you hardly ever get to
shoot anything in in sequence right and
i just adored him and i just think the
world of him and anytime i see him it's
like just
i'm sure he comes to some of those shows
like when christopher guest and michael
mckee and your husband are playing he'll
show up i'm sure steve martin has showed
up you know i don't remember seeing
those two guys really yeah i see him in
new york when i'm um steve martin wrote
this wonderful um
show called bright star he wrote the
music for it and um edie oh my god i'm
so bad you're married to paul simon
edith raquel mikhail raquel ricky
brickhell raquel raquel it's a tough
name well no it's not a tough name
remember the song the song her hit songs
well i remember
one that they wrote for the show that i
sang on called sun's gonna shine again
really yeah
sun is gonna shine again sun's gonna
shine again sun is gonna shine again the
sun's gonna shine again
um
i love it it's a wonderful song and so
anyway i i didn't do the show i did the
uh the workshop of it right
um and so but i'd i'd met steve a couple
of times and he's he's a very
interesting man and he's very sweet but
but marty's like you know because we had
such a he's just out there very
he's he's just he's the best
hey guys i'm tom welling i used to play
clark kent on smallville i'm michael
rosenbaum i used to play lex luthor on
smallville join us every week as we go
back
way back i'm excited i know are you
can't wait join tom welling and michael
rosenbaum every week as they rewind
every episode of smallville and discuss
their experiences with friends fans and
co-stars talkville the ultimate
smallville podcast
you